my name is Miles Morales and in my world
I'm the one and only spider-man that is
until he showed up and it snow on the
Cape I think it's cool spider-man
doesn't wear it cake hey guys
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy I'm from
another another dimension
how many more spider people are there
hey tell us this could literally not get
any weirder it can get weirder my name
is Peter Parker I'm supposed to save the
whole world
you can't think about saving the world
you have to think about saving one
person miles where did you go
spider-man turn invisible not in my
universe this is incredible some kind of
fight-or-flight thing what's that I
think this is a cape hey everybody it's
Charlie we got brand new spider-man
footage to break down you probably
picked up on some of the more obvious
Easter eggs there's some really cool
ones in here too especially for the
version of spider-man that got to where
Doctor Strange escaped we also see a
couple extra new suits in the background
too so we'll break it down we already
started a new round of that spider-man
ps4 game giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
spider-man related comment on the video
the funny thing about some of these
extra suits too is that yeah they're
really cool but they also exist within
the spider-man ps4 game not every single
one of them but most of them so the
trailer is mostly dedicated to in
trowing the other versions of spider-man
but also in telling him why he's not
supposed to wear a cape real heroes
don't wear capes every meme you've ever
seen about capes the incredible scene no
capes another day say when his cape
snagged on a missile Thunder head the
brightest balls
April 23rd 57 hit caught in a jet
turbine diner guys they're gone hey
father splashdown sucked into a vortex
nuggets there's a whole bunch of new
footage of them showing off some of
Miles Morales is unique spider-man
powers like his camouflage ability it's
mostly a fear base so he doesn't really
know how to use it yet that's why he
automatically goes invisible when they
hear that really loud sound in kingpins
office boom pop invisible this is
incredible some kind of fight or flight
thing what's that they do a really good
job of reminding you that Peter Parker's
middle name is Benjamin he was given
that name in honor of Uncle Ben you see
a lot more of the training montage when
he's still wearing the Spiderman
Halloween costume that's actually what
he's running around it you can see the
elastic around his legs like it doesn't
quite fit him right that's just because
it's a one-size-fits-all Halloween
costume Gwen Stacy's saving them after
miles smashes his nuts on a tree
practicing his web slinging in the
forest
cool new intros for all the different
versions of spider-man that they're
gonna have in this at least the ones
that we know about I'm sure there'll be
references to other ones but I think
they want to keep the movie from getting
too crowded they tease the web of fate a
little bit when you see gwen stacy
falling through universes like you see
what looks like spider strands
connecting all the different universes
of the multiverse the reason why i don't
think we're gonna see a ton of madam web
web of fate web of life and destiny is
just because that's more of a shattered
Dimensions thing when they go like
really crazy so they might get into that
in sequels but the whole idea is is that
the web of life and destiny is a
three-dimensional construct in five
dimensional space which acts as a model
of the entire multiverse like you're
looking at the entire multiverse all at
the same time in five dimensional space
it's maintained by the master weaver
super powerful character that exists
somewhere above madam web in the
hierarchy of spider deities and also the
other spider deities themselves which
give a lot of the versions of spider-man
across the multiverse their different
abilities as you wish I should leave you
for now but you are still the chosen one
and when the time comes for the ultimate
battle I will return and send for you
that
cannot escape it is your so imagine in
this movie spider-man into the spider
verse they're just dipping their toe in
the multiverse like oh my god there's
other versions of me they could do
shattered Dimensions in a sequel where
they go really crazy with that idea
there's that big chasing with his uncle
the Prowler through traffic and that big
car accident that just shows you some of
his abilities once he's starting to
learn how to use them there's actually
an Easter Egg for A Tribe Called Quest
here on top of the cab here it says
babble on blood cloth that's a reference
to a song by A Tribe Called Quest called
Babylon blood clot there's a lot of
Easter eggs for people that work on the
movie the music that they're using for
it in addition to just general Spider
Man comic book references then you get
all the funny scenes about him not
wearing a cape so he's got the yellow
one he just rips it right off of him no
kid heroes don't wear capes but when he
finds the version of spider-man's
costume that has dr. Strange's cape
attached to it that's a reference to
ultimate spider-man the cartoon series
where he got to wear dr. Strange's cape
briefly so we'll see whatever the
explanation is for spider-man in the
Ultimate Universe having a copy of it
and I know the clasp looks a lot like
the eye of agamotto but unless Doctor
Strange in this universe is dead in
spider-man at one point became the
sorcerer supreme within the Ultimate
Universe this has got to be something
else because Doctor Strange would never
give that away on permanent loner or
anything like that because it looks like
these suits have been here for a long
time but that is not the only time a
version of spider-man has worn a cape
spider-man 2099 has a makeshift cape of
sorts I mean it's a really short cape
but it's still technically a cape there
was a version of spider-man from Earth
802 1:9 that never became the superhero
spider-man but did wear a costume like
his became a performer he wore a cape
that had spider prints all over it there
was a version of spider-man that wheel
did mill near in thus got all of Thor's
armor so he was wearing Thor's cape in
that instance that was Marvel Adventures
number 40 non-canonical it's still
really funny if you've ever seen this
image traveling around the web they're
just making fun of the fact that
spider-man has been such a popular
character appeared so many times for
such a long period that he's done almost
every single thing every twist you could
possibly imagine every type of costume
he is probably worn it in some case but
going from a left to right the costumes
you've seen the background here on the
far left are the secret war black suit
not to be confused with the plural
Secret Wars which was a completely
different event there's no costume on
the dummy right next to it the one next
to that with a cape obviously like I
said from the ultimate spider-man
cartoon series where he wore doctor
Strange's cape the black suit on the
other side of them looks like it could
be a reference to the symbiote costume
from spider-man 3 because of all the
solid black costumes that Spiderman has
worn most of them have had white emblems
or other colors so without any part of
this lighting up it's kind of hard to
pinpoint which one this is but it looks
kind of shiny none of the symbiote
costumes are shiny so you can let me
know which one you think this is and
then obviously the big time stealth suit
is the green one on the right of that
then to the far right is the spider
armor mark - most of these suits you can
unlock inside spider-man ps4 with
exception to the Doctor Strange version
but you can actually travel to the
sanctum within the game but because this
movie is coming out in December will
pricey a couple more clips and trailers
for it amidst Avengers 4 trailer Captain
Marvel trailer and spider-man far from
home trailers think of the same way that
they did things last year with Black
Panther and the infinity war trailers
like once we hit December you started to
see more of that stuff this year we just
also have a Spider Man movie coming out
next summer so it'll be thrown in - fun
fact about that original spider-man Home
Coming trailer it at that very fake
scene of Iron Man and spider-man flying
through the city together they did that
exact same thing when we got to the
infinity war trailer so I'll be
interested to see which of the Avengers
4 trailer scenes and the Spider Man far
from home trailer scenes or totally fake
that's all part of the fun like you
break it down like it's all genuine you
look for Easter eggs and special moments
and clues then you go back and you look
and say which of these scenes is most
likely to not wind up in the actual
final cut of the film Joe Russo director
of the movie actually just did a QA
talking about Avengers 4 a trailer and a
couple of things from the movie so I'll
try to include that in a video tomorrow
if I don't do a separate video about it
but we're getting closer and closer so
what will happen is is I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post a new Marvel
click here for the new Infinity Ward's
deleted scene and alternate ending and
click here for that new Dragon Ball
super Broly trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you